I'm a developer Advocate with explosion
worth makers of Spacey um the open
source NLP library and also the Prodigy
which is a super cool annotation tool I
started interning with them about six
months ago a few months after I finished
my undergraduate degree
um my academic background is in
linguistics but I've fallen in love with
programming and machine learning after
doing a few really cool projects on my
own and then of course with explosion as
well I'm really loving being involved in
this open source software thing
educating the community around Spacey
and I've learned really so much in the
past six months
um today I'm going to talk about one of
the components within Spacey that I have
been exploring
um all right so how do we deal with
entities within entities in certain
entity extraction problems uh today
we're going to be answering that with
this cute cat which is the mascot for
Spacey's big cat or Spain categorizer
pipeline component
all right
so we're going to be looking at two
examples uh throughout the presentation
in the first one we're doing some
analysis of the recent crisis we're
looking to extract names organizations
and dates time substrings from a
document
we can look at this crazy situation with
FTX I can't really believe what's been
happening with that so I decided to put
it in here
um between this and what's going on with
Twitter I thinking maybe AI should
probably just take over Humanity uh
sooner rather than later
so anyways uh for this first example
these substrings are called names
entities Sam there is a named entity in
order to extract them from a text you'd
use a name to entity recognition machine
learning model
Spacey has one of these uh works pretty
well for situations like this with
typical gamed entities like people
organizations or dates these substrings
are mainly proper nouns they're composed
of tokens with clearly defined
boundaries so that's kind of why they're
called named entities
um there's a lot of different
applications for this type of model
there's a lot of different reasons why
you'd extract names and organizations
from a text as you might imagine
um
so moving on to the second example the
substrings are labeled here look a lot
different than the ones in the top
example so you know just the problem
here and we'll go into this more is
we're trying to figure out whether
certain conditions are being benefited
or worsened from a review of a
medication
so we label all the conditions in green
there
um the positive effects are benefits in
pink and the adverse drug effects Ada in
yellow
these substrings the ones labeled there
aren't really entities they're not the
typical spans you want to extract from a
document and named entity recognition
instead of being proper nouns like in
the first example they contain a lot of
different syntactic units they're longer
they're arbitrary and a bit more
complicated and they even overlap in
some cases
this is a tough problem because the
model you would use to solve the first
example the name entity recognition
model doesn't do these types of
arbitrary labeled spans and it
definitely doesn't do these overlapping
spans
so we need a model that goes beyond the
typical entity recognition Beyond
typical entities and that handles a wide
variety of these labeled spins
um within a text
so
um
sorry sorry so these are two different
problems in the top example we're
labeling these clearly defined tokens
these proper nouns
and we train a named entity recognition
model to learn how to identify these and
in the second example we have much
different labeled spans things that are
not named entities and that means by
Design and named entity recognition
model will not work
so luckily the Spacey team has come up
with a solution
which is a model that can learn to
recognize these non-entity spans
okay so in this talk I'm going to start
by introducing a bit about what named
entity recognition is what problems it
solves and how exactly it does that I'll
then go into what problems it doesn't
solve as easily and how we might look at
solving them instead
we'll take a dive and just basically a
span cat component how it works it's use
cases and the differences between spam
cat and ner
I'll be connecting all of this to the
two examples we saw before so you'll get
pretty familiar with them
all right
um so in natural language processing
uh named entity recognition is the task
of extracting entities like people
organizations or dates from a text as we
saw
there's lots of different types of
entities you might want to get and some
data sets like the onto notes if you
know it there might be upwards of like
10 different types of labeled entities
the applications are really broad for
this
um
those bands with the names of the state
recognition model were extract have
clear token boundaries comprised of the
same syntactic units proper nouns so
they have very low internal structure
they're very simple easy to pick out
we're going to look at a very brief
overview of how that works um just you
can get a sense of why it works very
well for this type of labeling but maybe
why I want might not look so well for
some of the later situations
okay so in Nar model we'll take a
sentence and then create an array of
labels to tag individual tokens with
these labels come in two forms the
beginning label will start the span and
then the intermediate labels come for
each subsequent token so each token is
classified into this given set of entity
labels a token cannot have more than one
label and each token is classified
independently so it's very sensitive to
these boundaries
the outputs are tagged left to right and
then the next tags will have some sort
of dependency to the tag that came
before it so it entangles the
predictions and provides a certain set
of context to the later tokens
the model tries to find the most likely
output sequence for any given input
um but again it's a sequence where each
individ input token only gets one output
label and each token is tagged
independently
this sort of bottle works very very well
for proper nouns named entities as you
might say that's why it's called that
it's designed this way and there's a lot
of problems that can be solved using
this approach
um it's a pretty popular model because
of the wide variety of these
applications and it's gotten to be very
very good it's done it does what it's
designed for as one might expect
um
oh
however when you start to look at some
native Institute recognition pipe
problems you begin to see that they
might pose a problem for some ner models
um
okay so going back to the second example
in the first slide
um we're going to look to extract the
medical conditions from the review of a
prescription drug with the hope of
finding out whether certain conditions
are benefited or worsened by the drug
so this review is not quite real it's
been changed a bit for simplicity's sake
in practice the reviews I'm working with
do not look this nice enough in fact
this would probably be flagged as a bot
review in any normal pipeline but we're
just going to do a bit of a pretending
for now
um so I can get the point across them so
um with this example on the slide
there's several substrings that we might
be interested in in order to be able to
solve this problem
um in the sentence we'll label all the
conditions which is the substrate
containing the medical symptom that can
be benefited or worsened by medication
so here in this example that would
include the joint pain the dizziness and
the headaches our conditioned span
should be the simplest form of the
condition but without excluding
important information so for example
we'll take a joint pain as one labeled
substrate because pain is not quite
specific enough especially if you're
talking about certain types of
medications
um but as you can see these are your
typical named entities in fact they're
not really entities at all this is a
special problem
but let's let's see if we can still try
to solve it within any r model
so if we were to try to solve this with
ner we would label the spans and then
train an ner model to recognize them
based on previous experience I've had I
can imagine this would work all right
even though they're not proper nouns in
the way the model is used to it most
likely would be able to learn the spans
um and then we probably try to do some
sort of text classification model
because remember we're trying to figure
out if the conditions are being
benefited or if there's some sort of
adverse effect from the drug
so except the text classification model
isn't going to work when there are
sentences with multiple conditions and
different effects
so you need to do some sort of fancy
slice thing and cut down the sentences
and then do text classification on the
bits this would allow you to isolate the
effects of certain conditions but it
would be a bit of work to figure out
where how and where to cut especially
with a purely rule-based approach review
data is a bit messier than this in
practice
so it's doable but definitely not ideal
and just a little bit of a tangent my
colleague Edward talks about a lot of
these problems on his blog on Halsey
which is his project for medical
supplements sort of doing the same idea
so anyways if we did this sort of
pipeline we'd have to do two components
the ner and the text classification and
there'd be lots of complications lots of
edge cases
so what if we try to think about this
problem in a slightly different way
in this example I normally want to
extract the condition spans the green
ones but also the entire phrase or span
detailing the effect whether it's
positive or negative
so we'd have two different effect labels
and if we do this successfully we'd be
able to classify the segments with only
one model instead of both an ner and a
text classification component in our
pipeline
this would make it a ton easier to see
whether certain conditions are being
benefited or worsened and we wouldn't
have to cut up the sentence at all like
we would have in the last example
um because it's already done as part of
the model training the data labeling
process
however we might begin to run in some
problems if we try to use an Nar model
to learn to recognize these labeled
spans
so even though you're still extracting
these bands of text
um
there's a few reasons why Nar models
can't handle this sort of data first of
all the effects spans the benefit and
the Ade spins are rather arbitrary they
consist of sentence fragments and a lot
of different syntactic units they're
longer than any other model would
normally do with and in some cases most
importantly the effect and the condition
spans overlap there's a entity quote
unquote within an entity so these aren't
the typical named entities in the first
example
or even the somewhat okay condition
spans that the Nar model might be able
to learn this is something the Nar model
cannot do simple by the way it was
designed
along with other things the sequence
based AR model has a lot of edge
sensitivity so it predicts these single
token based tags that are very sensitive
to boundaries which is not very helpful
for arbitrary or overlapping spans
so in order to solve my problem of
extracting both the effects and
conditions bands from our text
we're going to need to find another
solution
and with that I will introduce species
and categorizer component also known as
spam cat this is a trainable pipeline
within Spacey's open source library and
it can handle overlapping and arbitrary
spans
so the Spacey team came up with a
solution because they saw this need
within the NLP Community to label these
non-named entity spans applications like
we just saw and it's really cool what
they've been able to accomplish with it
I'm going to go into house bandcat works
and how to use it in a second but first
I want to talk briefly about Spacey
so as I mentioned uh Spacey is the open
source natural language processing
Library if you don't know it it's
maintained by my lovely colleagues and
me at explosion there's a lot I like
about spacey but I'm going to focus
today on the idea of customizability
without compromising the developer
experience
So within a Spacey project or pipeline
you have the option to change add update
customize all the components within your
pipeline but they still have sensible
defaults when you first start
so the config file there's a
configuration file that lays out all the
different controls you can have for your
project or components pipeline in one
place it's initialized with the set of
defaults as I said but you can swap out
everything to fit your problem and what
you want to do
additionally all the variables are named
in the configuration file so they're not
hidden away under abstraction layers now
we really do try to implement these
customizable and transparent Solutions
we find that really important and we can
see this in spin cap
so spin cat would be part of your
project pipeline this pipeline would
include a tokenizer either one from
Spacey or even something else if you
wanted you can just swap that out in the
configuration file we'll see that a bit
on the next slide
um the pipeline might also include some
other components such as a tagger or
parser depending on your project and
what you needed so for example in the
following slides we might see that
there's an option to suggest sub trees
bands of a text within your spin cap
model
and for that for the sub trays you might
need a dependency parser within your
pipeline so you can just add that in
your configuration file as well
um when you're going to start with spoon
cut you can use the add pipe feature to
either add the default spin cap model or
even add a custom spigot model as you
have trained and defined in the
configuration file
um
okay so on the Spacey website there's
these training quick start guide and
this allows you to generate a config
file you choose the individual
components with cute little check boxes
for your pipeline and then it generates
this file with the recommended settings
um the config file within our pipeline
components has some pretty neat features
so I went over this a little bit um but
it's a single source of Truth for all
your components none of the variables
are hidden behind obstructions and all
the settings are in this one file this
makes it easier to see what's going on
not have stuff hidden under too many
abstraction layers it also gives you the
flexibility to customize the
architecture by simply swapping out
components in the file
for example you can swap out the
suggestor function pressmancat we'll
talk about that more in a bit by just
changing its definition in the
configuration
something custom you've built um
excuse me and then update all the
dependent variables in the configuration
as well
okay
whoo
there's more talking than I've done in a
while
okay so there's
a few different ways to visualize these
spans
um Prodigy is exposure into annotation
tool and it is a great way to label this
band data so it has a built-in recipe to
handle these labeled spins
also you can use this
oh excuse me you can use the splicity to
visualize these spins as well
it simply swims up a web server and
allows you to view these labeled spans
um visualization can be super helpful in
debugging the training process and then
also having good data with consistent
annotations is super important for model
training which is why I'm saying this
oh
okay so let's go into a bit about how
spam cat works
um what's going on under the hood
so spanka has two main parts a suggestor
and a classifier oh that is the wrong
side a suggestor in a classifier
then you see the duster as the name
might suggest uh suggest possible spare
candidates and then it feeds them into
the classifier
which then scores them
so there's so many different
possibilities for these adjuster
function um including a few purely
rule-based approaches and then a more
machine learning solution
um so we'll take an engrams adjuster for
now
you can set the underground length for
your data and then it breaks the text up
into chunks so here we have uh engram
length of two and it's broken the text
up into chunks of two tokens each
so then the classifier will take over
and the scores labeled predictions for
each span
so it includes context from the whole
engram span so in this case the whole
joint pain span
and that way the classifier can catch
important informative words from within
the span
um so the interval spans as classified
as one unit so although the tokens of
the span use contextual representations
um
unlike the ner model it is one unit
instead of token based um
so the classifiers first starts with an
embedding layer um it takes took to back
representations
um to work with the words numerically
and then it goes through a pooling layer
um
So within the so this reduces these
spins and encodes the context So within
the output it pulled array there is a
first token and a last token and this
marks the span boundaries
and then there's the mean of all the
choke to wrap representations in the
span to encode context and then finally
the Max from which took to that
representation
so then the scoring later Returns the
model predictions and the label
probabilities by performing this
multi-label classification on the
pulitzban
um all right so let's go back to the
suggestor function
um
okay so in the 0.5 release of space c
experimental we added three rule-based
suggestive functions the subtree
suggestor suggests spans based off their
syntactic dependence the chunks
suggestor suggests chunks using a
non-truck iterator and in the sentence
Jester suggests sentence fans
additionally there's the option to
suggest fans based on npam as we saw and
then our machine learning approach to
span suggestion is called spin finder
and it identifies span boundaries by
suggesting possible start and end tokens
so it suggests a lot fewer and more
precise candidates than the ngraph
suggestor which does improve training
time and memory usage for your spin cat
component if you're interested in
learning more you can check out our
space experimental repo on GitHub
um in practice though the method used is
just fans the classifier depends a lot
on the project you're doing so you can
buy some model towards a higher recall
or Precision by changing the amount of
candidate spans there are which is super
cool super super cool
um okay
I think there's a delay in the sides
okay there we go
um this is an example implementation of
the engram suggestor in this example
there are quite a few bad candidates
because we're taking all the possible
spans of links one two and three so spam
cat will have a hard recall using this
method because the number is pink and it
is pretty high so if you wanted to have
a lower recall and bias towards
Precision
um spin finder or the noun junk iterator
might be a better option but again it
really depends on like your project and
your use case and what you need and want
okay so we'll go into a little bit of
review uh the differences between any
iron spin cats some things bank at does
a bit differently so as we just saw in
the previous slides spooncat gives you
explicit control over your candidate's
fans via the suggestor function options
this does allow you to bias your model
towards Precision or recall uh or even
customize it further to fit your
specific needs
unlike the Nar model spam cat Returns
the predicted label probabilities over
the entire span which gives you more
meaningful confidences through threshold
against
um so by including the contacts from the
whole span with the pooling layer the
classifier can catch an important and
informative words from within this van
finally and most importantly there's a
lot less Edge sensitivity these
sequence-based Nar models will typically
predict single token based tags that are
sensitive to boundaries this is
effective in some cases for proper nouns
but not so helpful for phrases or
overthalking spans as we've seen
all in all I'm super Amazed by the
solution that the Spacey team came up
with for these NLP Community to solve
this problem and it's really really cool
to see what problems it allows us to
solve
okay so we have a lot of resources
already out there about spam cap which I
just wanted to point out
um we have amazing blog posts a video
and some example projects in our
projects repo we're also active on all
the discussion forums so if you're
interested in any of this further
there's more for you and we're here for
you too
all right uh thank you so much for
listening this was my first talk ever so
I really appreciate you being here I was
a little nervous
um I think we have time for a couple of
questions but if there's anything
further I can be in The Gather Town
afterwards or in the Discord so just
bring me there
thank you for presenting and I could not
tell this was your first talk it was
very very well done so and yes Vincent's
chat says clap clap clap yep indeed
um
great talk by you have so we did have
one question uh but looks like Vincent
already answered it
um so this was about oh we have a lot of
a lot of chat here
um it was around you can span catch deal
with split spans uh referring to the
same concept unit
so for example uh when the same concept
is scattered between non-connected spans
example it is required to perform a
blood test before the checkup as part of
the insurance instructions to make sure
that the patient has no prior conditions
let me just maybe show this bit because
that is the example and Vincent answered
saying they would be identified as two
different spans now I think
yeah I'm pretty sure that's the case
um yeah you would label them as two
different separate spans um
yeah
okay
uh all right so oh we have another
question by Lenny who asks
what's the difference between spam cat
and label Studio
I actually am not aware of label studio
um maybe Vincent has saying in the chat
okay
Vincent also says he's been uh get it
done after perfect
um all right we have I think one more we
have time for a question so let's share
John Pierce question can we use pan cat
to detect linguistic images example I
feel under a dark cloud Dark Cloud means
depressed humans use these images all
the time
I mean
um you could definitely train a model to
do this Bangkok is more about the the
labeled span so
um it would be really good for a dark
cloud because that's not super named
entity like
um
so it would it would work well for
labeling stuff like that and recognizing
stuff like that
um
but it's all about what model you train
the data you're training it on
um I mean this is super hard in the
medical reviews right because like
people don't generally say exactly how
they're feeling how they're feeling so
this is definitely a problem like that
needs to be solved yeah